l'extrême droite expulsé d'assassins
syndicat d'extrême droite s'est vu
interdire de local de panneaux et de
toute possibilité de distribuer des
tracts dans l'enceinte de l'université
d'assas c'est le conseil
d'administration de l'université qui a
pris cette décision en réponse aux
agressions violentes dont la faculté de
droit a été le théâtre depuis plusieurs
semaines reportage de niffer des
christian bale terre puisse aux
violences et aux incidents répétés à la
fac d'assas perpétrés par les étudiants
d'extrême droite de lui des excuses le
conseil d'administration a dit si
exclure lui des as de l'université une
décision annoncée par le président de
faerie de
la vie de l'université n'est pas troublé
par ces violences dans la mesure où elle
ne concerne que quelques dizaines
d'étudiants toujours les mêmes c'est à
dire les morts de l'idea d'une part et
d'autre part les malheureuses adhérents
ou sympathisants de l'unef id et dans
certains car d'autres mouvements comme
par exemple l'unique il ya eu des
difficultés avec lui déjà il ya quelques
semaines mais je tiens que l'on peut
être étudiant à sas passé une année à
sas sans être témoin d'un acte de
violence
plus des a été exclu du bénéfice du
règlement intérieur de l'université
notamment ce qui concerne le local les
panneaux d'affichage et la possibilité
de distribuer des tracts affichant la
volonté de s'opposer avec fermeté et en
faisant appel aux forces de l'ordre aux
provocations et à la violence au sein de
la faculté de réaction étudiants que
j'avais inscrit en onzième position
c'est une bonne décision pour
l'université puisque depuis des années
lui des as
malgré les avertissements qu'on lui a
donné et malgré toutes les chances que
l'université conseil d'administration
lui a donné à continuer à aller dans une
logique de violence donc le coup franc
était obligé de tomber le conseil
d'administration a fait ses
responsabilités et après une sanction
contre ce mouvement
qui n'agissait que pour le moment que
par la violence ça fait des années et
des années que l'extrême droite ultra
violentes se manifeste à assas en tapant
les étudiants bien évidemment les
vigiles et la cible de privilégiés qui
sont les étudiants politiques qui sont
marqués contre l'extrême-droite qui ont
fait 26 % d'un an des élections lost est
une solution qui était absolument
nécessaire